i spent the season with you know they
sean watson and you know i feel like you
know being with patrick last season both
of those guys
are pretty pretty similar into what they
bring to their team you know obviously
both of them are the franchise guys and
both on my highly competitive they come
in the building with the right spirit
the right attitude they work the right
way
and obviously they have the talent to
lead a football club and i think anytime
you have two two guys like that in that
position
in the same conference uh you know it's
going to be special especially once you
talk about getting into playoff football
and championship football um you know i
wouldn't mind playing against desean
watts in big games um feel like he's one
of those players that that brings it out
of you he makes you prepare the right
way and i'm sure patrick does that as
well
tyron matthew who has played both with
deshaun watson and with patrick mahomes
currently a teammate of patrick mahomes
we're looking for that next tom brady
payton manning rivalry the key
ingredient though is
both teams have to be able to dominate
their division so they're more likely to
cross paths in the postseason i don't
know if the texans can dominate the
south have a feeling the chiefs are
going to be dominating the west for
years to come but that leads to fill in
the blanks this morning peter and let's
start with the first one the best
current rivalry in the nfl is what
seattle san francisco and i think i
would have said even two years ago
pittsburgh baltimore i still love
pittsburgh baltimore and i think that's
going to be very good this year but that
monday night game last year you know the
chase mclaughlin jadavian clowney
russell wilson you know everybody had a
moment
in that game
that game last year i think cemented
seattle san francisco as the best in the
game today
and then it came down to the last game
of the regular season the sunday night
game in seattle the 49ers desperately
needed to win to win the division they'd
have been the five seed good luck
getting to the super bowl when you got
to go on the road in the wild card round
to get the the post season started yeah
i agree with you that's the best one
uh beyond that
you know chief's chargers got
interesting in 2018 when it looked like
maybe the chargers were going to win the
division but then they tailed off in
2019 and now who knows what direction
the chargers are going to go in i really
want to see someone rise up though and
give the chiefs everything they can
handle maybe the broncos are moving in
that direction but uh beyond 49ers
seahawks there really isn't one that
currently jumps off the page saints
buccaneers could be interesting this
year though with the quarterbacks who
have a combined age of as of monday 84
years old all right tyron armstead
speaking of the saints declares it to be
a super bowl or bust season in new
orleans that declaration is what
peter absolutely unequivocally true
because
next year on opening day when you line
up with tayson taysom hill at
quarterback
you have no idea what your team is going
to be one of the things that when i was
talking to john schneider after we
recorded my podcast this week one of the
things that we talked about essentially
is that
as long as you have russell wilson
you're never
picking players the caliber of jamal
adams sixth pick in the 2017 draft and
to me
the new orleans saints after this season
when drew brees heads to uh mike
florio's dressing room at nbc sports
i think one of the things you're going
to see
is a new
uh you know a new era in saints football
so you don't know what that holds
yeah i think at that point it will be
drew brees dressing room and i'll be
getting dressed uh in the hallway uh in
the hallway regardless yeah that's all
that's that's all reported that's all
speculated that has been confirmed by no
one just so we are clear on that
i think it's other than i think it's
yeah i i think it's uh ridiculous for
him to say that because of the pandemic
no one can go into this season with that
attitude because your season can get
derailed by this
microscopic invisible thing
that puts half of your team on ice for
multiple weeks and screws up everything
so i i just don't think that that any
team can go into this season with that
mentality in a normal year i'd agree
this year put super bowl or bust on the
shelf peter
i i disagree because
your attitude you know events can change
the course of history obviously
but just because you have that attitude
you know i think everybody on that team
in that organization should have that
attitude because of the unknown next
year
they're going for kind of the mini
version of the bill's four straight
super bowl losses with four straight
excruciating postseason exits they're up
to three
we'll see if it runs to four this year
all right one more real quickly lashon
mccoy will be what for the tampa bay
buccaneers this year he signed with the
team yesterday
you know
an insurance policy
i mean mike it's been seven years since
he's been an all-pro i mean he's 32
years old and again
and and frank gore is a lot older than
he is but my point about older backs is
that
you know don't go guaranteeing anything
whatever they give you is a bonus
there's a reason
why lesean mccoy wasn't signed until
july 29th
you know and and the reason is because
out there there's not a lot of trust
that he can be a 220 carry guy
and we'll see what happens maybe he can
be but as of now to me is an insurance
policy
i say non-factor all due respect i look
at it this way damien williams opted out
for the chiefs this week and if the
chiefs did not make a beeline for
lashawn mccoy to have him as the
alternative to clyde edwards hilaire
that tells you everything you need to
know about what andy reid the guy who
drafted lesean mccoy thinks
that mccoy has left in the tank right
now and the answer truth be told if
reid were attached to a lie detector
test would be nothing so i think he's
going to be a non-factor for the
buccaneer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports